hi everyone I'm back so I'm redoing
another term of vlogging they did behind
this project is that I'm gonna be making
short videos every week showing you what
it's like to be a student octopus from
the ground level so from a student's
perspective and to see whether this is
gonna mean effective form of access for
the university for the college but
things are gonna be a little bit
different this term I have to make some
changes to the format because amongst
other things my work commitments this
term are a lot more extensive than they
were last and this is the term writing
my master's project as you can see in
this helpful diagram you can see that
the master's project is a very large
part of the course before you cause the
Oxford and it's an opportunity to if you
really do well in it also somehow
pathway to a PhD which is what I'm
hoping to do so I'm not gonna have as
much time to make videos this term so
what proposed is that every week I'm
going to be still producing evolve but
that vlog has to be less than 5 minutes
long I had to include some time of me
talking about the work that I've been
doing some of the social stuff that I've
been doing although that's not gonna be
much and as a result of that I have to
include something that specifically
Oxford had to go to somewhere in Oxford
and sort of film it and talk about it as
a way of getting me at the house and
also actually showing what the kind of
things you can do in Oxford I also want
to include a sort of discussion topic
each week so that I want to kind of
gender more of a community feel to this
project because there's an awful lot of
you who watch these vlogs in the same
kind of position you want to get
information about but some of you have
very advanced plans about where you want
to go what subjects you want to do some
are just kind of starting out and sort
of testing the waters so I thought it'd
be really great if we could get us and
discussion going in the comments section
you guys could start talking to each
other as well I knew talking about to me
rather than me just talking to you with
that in mind and the five minute rule in
particular I better get a move on cuz
I'm gonna run out of time otherwise so
it ox return technically only started
today this is now Sunday at first week
but I've already even been back in
Hawke's Bay for about a week and a half
and that's to catch up on work to get
ahead of some work and just to prepare
for the term Rob and trying to hit the
ground running so what we're doing in
terms of the work on the atmospheric
physics side I've been looking at
stratospheric chemistry which is looking
at ozone in the middle atmosphere that
is
in three rather than oxygen to it is the
stable molecule and looking in the
processes which create it and destroy it
and the relative race that those
reactions take place at different levels
in the atmosphere which is really cool
and very relevant if you've ever heard
of the ozone hole problem over
Antarctica and now Australia that's
where a lot of this stuff comes into
direct play in terms of theoretical
physics which is what most of my time
doing I've been looking at field
theories so the connection between
filler theory and group theories and the
economical quantization of classical
field theories into quantum field
theories which is an awful lot of very
hollow maths and I've spent an awful lot
of times right and it's it's great to
have a Eureka moments but like
everything comes together and you
suddenly like oh my god
this won't make sense I need to have a
couple more gory bits like that I think
well here's how but it's been really
good reason you actually to get really
in depth with it's been actually quite
enjoyable even though it's been an awful
off work on the social side of things
because I've been doing so much work
I've just been in the library pretty
much all the time I haven't done that
much the only other sort of luxury if
you like I'm gonna allow myself this
time is going to the gym with some
friends but other than that not much the
only thing which happened this past week
was we had a Bop last night I've
mentioned BOTS before with parties
normally themed in college this week it
was chief stations so you had people
trying to dress up either on their own
or in teams as you know cheap stations
for instance to my friends when it Scott
Fosters I mean leave to your imagination
have a bit that I went as Barbican quite
literally Barbie can I imagine those
photos are gonna come back and haunt me
at some point I'm gonna have to cheat
because of the time constraints on the
video and count that bop as the specific
orcs of thing because in defence my
defense I normally wouldn't have to
explain the rules of the video at the
start so that's the specific opposite
thing in terms of the discussion I want
to kick things off by finding more about
you guys my audience I want to find out
what stage in you're applying to
universities you are whether you're in
GCSE whether you're in a level whether
you're another university news like
watching these or something like that I
want to find out what my
viewers alike and yet you guys talking
to each other so say which course you
thinking of applying to which university
you think of applying to if you know
which colleges you thinking to applying
to and see if we can talk in the
comments and if you can talk to other
people who have got similar sort of
plans for their lives I think that's
about it for the time being
not that much has happened recently
because I've just been sat in the
library doing work this is going to be
very serious terms for me so I'm gonna
have to try and make sure I do these
interesting things on the side to stop
making Gaeng mad so a lot going on next
week which I will fill you in in due
course right that's it for now thanks
for watching and I will see you next
week